richard barron's there now a significant
story is breaking tonight regarding
germany and the supply of weapons to
ukraine our security and defense editor
deborah haynes is here in kiev so what
have germany decided to do well germany
which remember was the country that
didn't back uh sending lethal aid to
ukraine up until this conflict has just
announced that it's going to send a
thousand anti-tank missiles and 500
stinger missiles which are the um sort
of surface-to-air missiles that you can
that a soldier can carry and launch from
his shoulder it's a huge significant
reversal of policy by a country that has
until now resisted lethal aid for
ukraine uh something that the uk the us
canada had been doing provided providing
these anti-tank weapons ammunition to
the country it's the thing the single
thing that ukraine needs most and it
comes after the defense secretary the
british defense secretary yesterday
hosted a a conference of nations or
about 25 nations there he spoke to two
others as well
trying to get everyone to sort of sign
up to give military aid such as weapons
and also medical supplies and also the
uk has said that it would help with the
delivery of these suppliers remember
this is a war zone it's not easy just to
get stuff in
but this is a huge development by
germany and it also shows that how
russia's actions here in ukraine in
defiance of western warnings has done
something that
since the cold war has never happened in
terms of galvanizing really genuinely
galvanizing the nato alliance to
actually do real action they did do it
after 2014 in terms of mobilizing forces
more spending more on their defense
budgets but it wasn't enough to deter
russia's malign activities
and so tonight this real strengthening
of policy and posturing by germany yeah
i mean it's a hugely significant
political
moment for germany isn't it it is
germany it traditionally it has got uh
it has had you know close close ties
with russia very very important economic
ties
so has countries like like hungary like
italy all members members of nato but
all with slightly different policies
towards russia than for example the
baltic states which are very hawkish and
the uk and the u.s that
have a very strong line about um
standing or a relatively strong line
about standing up to
russian threats so yes a significant
move by germany also the ukrainian
president said that france too had said
it was going to send in weapons we've
heard from the netherlands that they're
going to be sending in stinger missiles
this country the the armed forces here
have succeeded in slowing at least the
russian advance we don't want to
overplay it but we heard from the the
british armed forces minister this
morning saying that russia has not
achieved its objectives and this is an
invading force it has limited time to be
able to achieve those objectives until
its supplies run out
okay deborah thank you very much indeed